where we're increasing the workforce
there's ten and a half thousand more
nurses this year compared to last year
we're on track to deliver our Manifesto
commitment for 50 000 more nurses with
over 30 000 of those already achieved
but it's not just about the number of
Staff it's also about treating patients
in the right place how we maximize the
use of technology and how we give
patients a better experience and so
using that technology to provide a
clinical safety net at home or in
residential care and not requiring
people to stay longer in hospital than
they need to do that's all part of
embracing a more integrated way of
treating patients that brings the
hospital and the community much more
closely together
well let's bring in sadio charity who's
at the Department of Health and Social
care and Saudia a billion pounds over a
couple of years seems like a very large
sum of money but given the state of the
NHS at the moment is it going to be
enough
well it's a plan but and it's been
described as a blueprint but much of
what is in this plan as is actually
already in operation it just needs to be
rolled out a bit more widely for example
those virtual awards that you mentioned
just a short while ago seven thousand of
those beds already in existence that's
due to be rolled out to to cover 50 000
patients by the end of this two-year
period and some of the stuff that's in
this it was just published a couple of
hours ago so we're still going through
it but some of the things in here you'd
almost ask why the NHS doesn't already
have this so things like clear plans and
strong leadership stuff that you might
expect the NHS to already have but the
Crux of this plan is to ease that
pressure off emergency departments so
there's a real focus on cutting
ambulance wait times addressing that
issue and also getting people in and out
of emergency departments quicker so
that's why the more ambulances the more
medical um medically trained as
technicians but also these same day
emergency Ward so that people can come
in and go and not have to stay overnight
in hospitals that is considered to be a
key to reducing the pressure on the NHS
it's a two-year plan backed by a one
billion pound fund and it covers lots of
different things including working from
home for some NHS staff including 111
call handlers and there's also a focus
on getting patients to go back home
quicker so rehab and physio to be done
at home where they used to be done in
hospitals more home visits those virtual
beds that you talked about also a
quicker discharge of patients who are
medically fit but it is a plan that is
already being criticized by the labor
party who say that it Waters down the
standards for patients and that even if
the government were to hit the targets
that have set for itself patients will
still be left to wait longer than is
safe
thanks very much